[Musik]
plötzlich ist man oder frau ein niemand
ausgelöscht
nicht mehr existent für einen staat und
eine gesellschaft die gerade im begriff
sind sich neu zu formieren
wie in slowenien 1992
das damals menschen aus allen
staatlichen registern gestrichen wurden
diese kafkaeske geschichte erzählt der
slowenische auto mihama zini in seinem
bike on werse erschienenen roman du
existierst nicht den er selbst auch
verfilmt hat bibiana 1992 eine
schwangere frau will in einer klinik ihr
kind auf die welt bringen
[Applaus]
war es nun beginnt ist ein
bürokratischer albtraum die junge frau
existiert amtlich nicht und ist somit
nicht versichert obwohl sie seit jeher
in slowenien lebt und arbeitet einen
jugoslawischen pass besitzt wurde sie
gelöscht
im kern der geschichte geht es um
identität denn der staat entscheidet
plötzlich du bist nicht zu wenig aber
was bist du dann auf einmal sind alle
dokumente ungültig kreditkarte personal
nichts funktioniert mehr
[Musik]
die hamas ihn liebe schreibt einen
vorgang der sich 1992 über 25.000 mal
wiederholte nur slowenen bekamen
automatisch die slowenische
staatsbürgerschaft
alle anderen die aus serbien bosnien
kroatien oder anderen teilen
ex-jugoslawiens stammten mussten einen
antrag auf einwanderung stellen nur
keiner teilte es ihnen mit deshalb
wurden sie einfach aus allen
melderegistern gelöscht und verloren
alle rechte die folgen waren dramatisch
einige wurden über die grenze deportiert
mitten hinein in den bürgerkrieg
man hat diesen leuten nicht mitgeteilt
was sie zu tun haben deshalb haben die
meisten gar nicht realisiert dass sie
nun fremde in slowenien sind weil sie
ihr ganzes leben in slowenien verbracht
hatten sie wurden zu illegalen
einwanderern gemacht und als sie
begriffen was da geschah mussten sie im
verborgenen leben
ethnische säuberungen nicht gewaltsam
nicht durch mord und vertreibung sondern
als einfacher bürokratischer akt
dabei haftet slowenien das image an sich
den blutigen nationalistischen
konflikten in ex-jugoslawien geschickt
entzogen zu haben
der bürgerkrieg 1991 dauerte kaum zehn
tage
bekam die neue regierung so etwas wie
einen adrenalinschub und dachte aber
wir brauchen doch einen feind und so
haben sie einen neuen feind geschaffen
all die leute die in anderen republiken
ex-jugoslawiens geboren waren
elf anvisiert ist einer der 25.000 die
damals zu fremden zu feinden erklärt
wurden
[Musik]
das ist nicht nur rassistisch sondern
ein genozid gegenüber der
zivilbevölkerung
ein
administrativer genozid weil wenn man
keine dokumente hat verliert man
dann verliert er seinen stolz weil man
dann ein niemand ist
ein niemand im freien fall dennis van
wesel witts kampf um neue papiere war
lange vergeblich er verlor seine arbeit
seine familie seine wohnung lebte eine
zeit lang wie ein obdachloser in einem
keller einsam und krank wenn ich zum
arzt bin um mich untersuchen zu lassen
haben sie mich nicht untersucht weil ich
plötzlich keine krankenversicherung und
kein geld mehr hatte man hat nicht
existiert mann war zu der zeit wenn ich
das sagen darf ein stück scheiße ein
stück scheiße für slowenien ich kann
vieles verzeihen aber der slowenischen
politik auch wenn sie sich entschuldigen
und den anderen den aufenthaltsstatus
zurückgeben sie bleiben für mich
aggressoren und ich werde ihnen nie
vergeben
seit jahrzehnten kämpft er von besirevic
mit anderen ausgelöschten um anerkennung
um kompensation und gegen die ignoranz
der slowenischen regierung gemeinsam mit
rad cross djokovic dessen vater damals
alle politischen und sozialen rechte
verloren
nicht nur einen teil sondern die ganze
kindheit und seit ich elf bin bis jetzt
kämpfen wir immer noch um die
anerkennung unserer rechte wir wollen
vor allem eine entschuldigung der
slowenischen regierung aber wir fordern
auch eine entschuldigung von der
europäischen union denn sie wusste von
diesem verbrechen damals in slowenien
die hamas roman zerrt nun dieses
verdrängte kapitel slowenische
geschichte ans tageslicht
und mehr noch er beschreibt die
mechanismen des unrechts die macht einer
kalten bürokratie durch die ein
verbrechen wie dieses erst möglich wird
auch heute will niemand darüber sprechen
und niemand wollte dass wir diesen film
drehen man schweigt lieber und will
nichts sei
deshalb habe ich dieses buch geschrieben
[Musik]